[Música]
todos nós estamos cada vez mais
dispostas a tudo aquilo que fizemos tudo
que fizemos tudo aquilo que te pensamos
tem hoje em dia um potencial de alcance
muito maior
agora imaginem os clientes
imaginem que em qualquer posto voz numa
rede social é um dia a notícia da
abertura em todos os telejornais
isso aconteceu em mim eu tenho dois
filhos um mini uma menina 7 e 6 anos de
idade
era agosto estavam studies férias
enquanto brincavam uma banca com
hiperatividade chamam a atenção mas se
ficar mente um certo conjunto em rosa e
azul não sei se sabem do que estou a
falar
eu fui à parte cerca de 20 páginas e o
que vi primeiro demasiado óbvio país
lugar na altura não vi autores e
ilustradores e editores não vi nada e
apenas com os olhos também lamentou
pedro e uma cartolina uma mãe que tenta
e se esforça por educar em igual data as
fotos que tirei em meio à pressa e até
com outras compras normal eram apenas
para alimentar uma conversa que tinha
pendente com o meu marido que é um pouco
mais à frente a uns dias tenho estado a
conversar sobre estaríamos nós pais e
sociedade é modular de alguma forma os
gostos preferências das crianças
francesas essas pois mais tarde no
mercado de trabalho se demonstram ser
desigualdades isso farmacêutica
é trabalhar numa empresa de software
eu saí da área da saúde na área da
tecnologia información 80% dos cargos
eram ocupados por mulheres xii em
tecnologia é a realidade é precisamente
a oposta sendo que os homens ocupam a
maioria dos cargos mas será que este
deve única e exclusivamente a diferença
entre os gêneros
homens e mulheres são diferentes é
verdade somos fisicamente frentes
isso é única e exclusivamente à biologia
nós podemos dizer o mesmo acerca dos
comportamentos e das preferências e tal
conversa com meu marido tenha sido
incendiada por um vídeo da bbc
numa experiência filmada existir um bebê
menino constituído e uma bebê a menina
como as calças e uma camisa no espaço
controlado onde havia todo tipo de
brinquedos espalhados pelo chão
pediram adultos voluntários quem
pertencem as crianças durante um bocado
grande maioria dos adultos tentou
entreter a menina com bebês com bonecas
com pulsos ensinando é embalar a vestir
e despir
já o rapaz a menina vestida de rapaz
ofereceram o egos carros-robôs ensinar
uma conduzida construir mas é claro que
é da nossa natureza de mulheres saber é
raro um bebê em trocar uma fralda certo
talvez não uma polêmica também há
relativamente pouco tempo na china o
google vai parar também as redes sociais
um funcionário que acabou de pis quando
estava as políticas internas de
diversidade e inclusão andante
precisamente isto que os números
diferentes números entre mulheres e
homens na área de tecnologia se deve
muito provavelmente as diferenças
naturais entre homens e mulheres
as mulheres são mais preocupadas com as
coisas dizer com as pessoas viviam
é natural que procurem áreas trabalho
mais ligadas às áreas
a essa área da saúde já os homens
preocupam mais com as coisas explicou o
motivo pelo qual estão em maioria nas
áreas de tecnologias engenharias
segundo eu e as mulheres são
naturalmente competitivas explica o
motivo pelo qual são os homens que
ocupam a maioria dos cargos de liderança
pois quando eu eu sou naturalmente
competitivo e tem uma maior apetência
por correr riscos mas tirar podemos
efetivamente fazer esta distinção é que
foi precisamente estes dois traços é
nossa como é que nós nos colocamos
planta competição e pranto risco que
investidores já em 2009 tentaram
perceber país identificaram duas tribos
uma tem design outra na ilha uma tribo
sociedade patriarcal e uma tribo da
sociedade matriarcal efetivamente na
sociedade patriarcal os homens
demonstraram ter muito mais tendência a
ser competitivos e ter uma grande
potência para o risco em valores até
muito próximo das sociedades ocidentais
atuais
no entanto na tribo matriarcal foram
elas as mulheres que mostraram ser muito
mais competitivas e ter muito mais
facilidade encarar o risco por este
estudo somos levados a concluir pelo
menos estes traços não são diferenças
naturais entre gêneros no chão sim
socialmente critics no entanto na
sociedade continuamos a responsabilizar
única e exclusivamente os pais pois
decisões na educação
até porque são eles que têm de viver com
as criancinhas grande momento 30 anos
certos em janeiro deste ano saiu nas
saias um estudo que nos deve preocupar
todos instigadores de três universidades
foram tentar perceber qual o efeito
estereótipos de gênero nas crianças na
entrada para a escola
dos cinco aos 60 anos de idade crianças
tão novas como a minha heroína com seis
anos identificavam está já sob
influência dos estereótipos de gênero
identificavam por exemplo como traço
maioritariamente masculinos a
inteligência ea genialidade não fosse
isto só preciso sentimento preocupante
este mesmo estudo demonstrou que isso
influenciava já os seus comportamentos
as meninas dessa idade mostravam-se
meses motivadas de esquerda iniciar
atividades por elas fossem pressionados
consciente para crianças mesmo mesmo
mesmo inteligente nesse mesmo estudo
percebeu se diz raparigas que apesar de
terem mais melhores notas terem bons
resultados na escola e atribuíam isso ao
seu trabalho ao seu estudo
já os rapazes iam isso como sendo
natural reflexo das suas competências
quando falamos de igualdade
é muito mais fácil confundir com a
defesa dos direitos das mulheres
mas a verdade é que também tem impacto
nos homens
em caso de divórcio por exemplo um homem
pai sabe à partida que independentemente
de tudo o que possa dizer lugar o provar
em tribunal é grande maioria das
decisões vai perder em função da mãe
isto deve se única e exclusivamente ao
seu sexo
mas então o que podemos fazer é verdade
é que neste país que tanto se fala e
poucos faz é difícil às vezes perceber o
que está ao nosso alcance
enquanto alguma medida tenta vídeo a à
luz logo flechas e põe sobre apontada em
sua direção
recentemente a polêmica estão loucos
medidas de discriminação positiva
quando a legislação foi aprovada que vai
impor cotas os conselhos de
administração das empresas cotadas em
bolsa
as medidas de discriminação positiva
parecem ter sempre esta aura de dúvida
não será discriminante para os homens
vêem os ultrapassados por mulheres única
e exclusivamente por seu sexo
a verdade é que para além de termos uma
opinião com tentar perceber se a data
tinha a informação para quanto mais não
seja podermos fundamentar a opinião que
temos
foi já em 1993 e na suécia foi aprovada
a legislação que impôs a paridade nos
partidos políticos 5050 está na 14
economistas tentaram perceber qual foi o
efeito dessa lei no país
a principal conclusão que tiraram e
qualidade das competências dos dois
políticos nacionais aumentou as dúvidas
que também existiam lá que mulheres
iriam substituir homens competentes não
se verificaram o que acabou por
acontecer foi que mulheres competentes
vieram ocupar o lugar de o mesmo de
lucros e atenção que isto não são
palavras minhas isso foi precisamente o
que os autores do estudo se irão chamar
e é crise do homem medíocre mas e temos
então um estudo um pouco mais próximo da
realidade que foi aprovada por portugal
na noruega um estudo do mesmo gênero foi
aplicado às empresas e principal
conclusão que tiraram e que na realidade
as empresas não tiveram uma dificuldade
china em contratar mulheres competentes
ela já lá estavam prontinhos a ser
promovidas só não o eram
mas voltando aos cadernos de atividades
e assim esse exame com tantas vezes foi
apelidada citando luís aguiar conraria
pai cronista extensor da igualdade
qual é o problema é ver caderno de
proteínas e para meninos
é muito fácil argumentar que não é por
uma menina holler determinado caderno
que entre de ir por exemplo pra
astronomia impedida não é mas é
condicionada é condicionada à mina e é
condicionado nino e negar experimentar a
ciência quando educandos uma criança o
nosso objetivo deve ser ampliado e os
horizontes aumentarem suas escolhas
nunca condicioná los neste país em que
tantos me têm de educar em que chama de
competição única e exclusivamente aos
países
ver devemos descuidar muitas vezes não
liberdade das leis de mercado para pura
e simplesmente nos responsabilizarmos
daquilo que deveria ser uma
responsabilidade de todos é que o que
estamos a dar às nossas crianças à
educação das gerações vindouras disse
uma preocupação em geral de toda a
sociedade
se nós criamos uma sociedade mais
equilibrada
se nós queremos um homem é melhor então
temos de prestar hoje na qualidade da
educação das nossas crianças
portanto se sabemos que os estereótipos
de gênero estão não só já presentes nas
nossas crianças não estão influenciando
de forma negativa e condicioná los
se sabemos que certos comportamentos não
são diferenças naturais entre gêneros no
chão sim socialmente embutidos
então deixamos desculpas porque o cargo
é uma responsabilidade de toda a
sociedade
[Aplausos]